angle a is a circumscribed angle on
circle o so this is angle a right over
here then when they say it's a
circumscribed angle that means that the
two sides of the angle are tangent to
the circle so AC is tangent to the
circle at Point C a B is tangent to the
circle at point B what is the measure of
angle a now I encourage you to pause the
video now and to try this out on your
own and I'll give you a hint a hint
it will leverage the fact that this is a
circumscribed angle as you could have as
you could imagine so I'm assuming you've
given a go at it so the other piece of
information they give us is that angle D
which is an inscribed angle is 48
degrees and it it intercepts the same
arc so this is the arc that intersects a
guess you could call it it intercepts
this arc right over here it's the
inscribed angle the central angle that
inscribes that that intersects that same
arc is going to be twice the inscribed
angle so let's this is going to be 96
degrees I could put three markers here
just because we've already used a double
marker the notice they both intercept
arc CB so you could you could some
people say the measure of Arc CB is 96
degrees the central angle is 96 degrees
the inscribed angle is going to be half
of that 48 degrees so how does this help
us well a key clue is that angle is a
circumscribed angle so that means AC and
a B are each tangent to the circle well
a line that is tangent to the circle is
going to be perpendicular to the radius
of the circle that intersects the circle
at the same point so this is this right
over here this right over here is going
to be a 90-degree angle and this right
over here is going to be a 90-degree
angle
OC is perpendicular to C a OB which is a
radius is perpendicular to B a which is
a tangent line and they both intersect
right over here at B now this might jump
out at you we have a quadrilateral going
on here a B OC is a quadrilateral
so it's sides are going to add up its
sides are going to add up to 360 degrees
so we could know we know we could write
it this way we could write the measure
of angle a plus 90 degrees plus 90
degrees plus another 90 degrees plus
another 90 degrees plus 96 degrees plus
96 degrees is going to be equal to 360
degrees is going to be equal to 360
degrees or another way of thinking about
it if we subtract 180 from both sides so
if we subtract that from both sides we
get the measure of angle a plus 96
degrees plus 96 degrees is going to be
equal to is going to be equal to 180
degrees or another way of thinking about
it is the measure of angle a or that
angle a and angle oh right over here you
could call it angle C Oh B that these
are going to be supplementary angles
that they add up to 180 degrees
so if we subtract 96 degrees from both
sides we get the measure of angle a
measure of angle a is equal to I don't
wanna make that look like a less than
symbol let me make it measure of angle
this one actually looks more like a
measure of angle a is equal to 180 minus
96 to see 180 minus 90 would be 90 and
then we subtract another 6 gets us to 84
degrees